[Music]
hello happy Friday TGIF welcome to et
live we are here today with Drake Bell
welcome thank you thank you how's it
going I'm doing well I'm so wysz Lacey
and we are here to talk about you have a
new EP out called honest tell me a
little bit about what you're trying to
say with this music what the message is
behind the EP oh man what's the message
I don't know you know this is just this
is a completely new direction for me
musically my last records are are
completely different and so it's
exciting to to get in the studio and try
something new you know I usually have a
it's it's usually a singer-songwriter
based and this week is a lot more
electronic a lot more dance inspired I
guess so yeah so it's exciting to see
what the fans are saying about it and
they're there they're reacting really
well to it so I'm excited was there
catalyst for you and going this new
direction um well I I just think my last
record that I did was a more of a cover
album I did a lot of the songs I grew up
loving and it was sort of just a fun
project I got to work with my idol Brian
Setzer who's my favorite guitar player
ever and it was just a fun little pet
project so it kind of made me miss
though
writing and doing my own material and
stuff so after a year or two of touring
that album and playing other people's
music doing cover songs and stuff I just
had to get back in the studio and and
write my own material and I don't know
if I consciously went this direction I
just I met this kid who was a great
producer we became good friends and I
suggested hey we should we should do
some songs together see how they turn
out and he took on this whole new life
and then we ended up doing the whole EP
together and I'm really happy with what
we got it's pretty cool yeah it's
awesome so you wrote all four songs tell
me about that experience as a songwriter
and what kind of things you draw
inspiration from in your life um I think
just life period you know just life in
general ups and downs and heartache and
happiness and sadness and you know some
of the songs on the record are about you
know how long is it going to take
this person to notice me leaves for
example is you know how I wonder how
many how long it's gonna take for my
phone to ring you know how what is it
going to take for this person to notice
me and then another one is is run away
which is just hey like that you know
that the video we did it's just fun
summer you know grab grab grab whoever
you love and want to spend the summer
with and hop in a car and go on a crazy
road trip and see where life takes you
kind of kind of vibe and and then rewind
is is sort of you know we had great
times and but no matter how much we try
and work and everything we can't rewind
and have what we had before and so as
you know loved loved lost some kind of
just just life in general really what
everybody goes through yeah yeah I like
your journal or something yeah is it
therapy for you I mean I think so yeah
yeah it's definitely you're you're
baring your soul I mean you know you
really sometimes you write lyrics and
you're like man I'm just gonna let
everybody hear that but but yeah it's
it's definitely therapeutic yeah yeah
now we are going to actually have an
exclusive performance from Drake the
title track honest but first I want to
talk a little bit about run away because
that was selected as your first single
yeah why was that the right one to put
out to the world first um I don't know I
just think it was it's uh it's a fun
summer vibe it's you know it's the
summer's here and and it just had that
that that fun sound you know I grew up
in Orange County on the beach and it's
just it just reminds me of being you
know back home and being a kid and and
putting the top down and heading to the
beach with your friends and and enjoying
summer that's fun perfect are you
working on a full LP you know I don't
know okay I might just I think because
the new music I'm working on I don't
know if I want to put together a full
album or just keep pumping these out cuz
it's it's really fun too
especially now with the access that we
have to our fans and and and with social
media and all this I mean there's no
reason we need to make them wait for us
to record 12 songs I mean that takes a
long time to write and record and
produce and master I'd rather just you
know get these great little blocks of
songs out and then and then send that to
them you know okay here's here's here's
or for for these couple months nope
here's the next floor I know here's the
next three or whatever I feel inspired
to ride at that time or anything it's
also more freeing because you're not
tied down to going oh we need but we
said we need 12 songs now you're
throwing on songs that you know you're
not really passionate about or just
might be throwaway songs you're forced
to put this there that they're here it's
kind of when it's ready it's out yeah
when it's ready put it out I love that
too it's a new age yeah that's great
really cool are you one of those people
that never stops writing or are you more
focused on you know this is out now I'm
gonna tour it and then I'll think about
writing more after it depends I mean
sometimes I just get up and I just have
to write and just feel like writing but
it kind of does go in stages it's is
it's okay I'm writing now now we have to
you know now we're recording and
everything is focused on what it's gonna
sound like and what you want to put into
it and then once it's once it goes to
tour it's a whole new beast because you
have to put the band because I play off
everything in the studio and then we
have to put put a band together so I
don't have a band that I record with or
anything but then then that then your
band leader then your you're focusing on
getting the great the right players and
what's the show going to look like and
what are we gonna wear and yeah what are
we gonna do for the audience and let's
this this this so yeah it's kind of just
you know take it in blocks like okay now
we're writing now we're preparing the
record now we're preparing for the show
now now we're out on the road and now
you know and then we get back home and
we write write some more so basically
it's just a huge undertaking all around
yeah now there's a question coming in
from James who wants to know who were
some of your biggest musical influences
let's see my biggest influences Beatles
is John Lennon still your favorite
Beatle definitely yeah I mean I love
Paul you know okay but uh how can you
not yeah even though he's not the real
Paul you know that even though the
imposter Paul McCartney
yeah the Beatles Beach Boys Queen Harry
Nelson Rufus Wainwright yeah I'm very
clear
dick with the the types of music that I
listen to and everything but I think I'm
mostly like a child of like sixties
music I just love hey well 50s do you
like in 50 60s that's my era you know I
mean like your parents did they kind of
my dad my dad had it in the house
growing up you know surfing USA and
Beach Boys all the Elvis and everything
so so that's where I saw it but I very
cool yeah but none of my family is is me
Musical at all I just grew up with them
being fans of music yeah but my brother
is nobody it's interesting but yeah
nobody plays plays an instrument
sometimes it's all you need just the
love of it yeah now I saw you were
tweeting about your tour coming up can
you reveal anything specific about the
tour when is it happening we're still
we're still just setting stuff up right
now it's in the very beginning stages
like I'm going to Colombia Mexico I have
some some some dates in the States I'm
playing on Sunday in Oceanside if
anybody's in Oceanside on Sunday at the
suit
what is it the surfer girl surfer girl
Pro super girl surf pro that's super
girl surfer prep sounds fun yeah it's
gonna be really cool and so we will be
playing that Sunday and then and then
yeah and then more shows will be coming
in and stuff but we're just we're just
gearing up right now all right now I
want to we'll come back around to music
but I want to talk to you about this
baby Avengers thing that you do oh my
goodness are you angling for a role in
the Marvel verse is that something you
would love to do well I do the voice of
spider-man so I'm on the Disney XD
animated cartoon the Marvel animated
cartoon I I'm spider-man and Peter
Parker oh that's where it came from so
that's where it came from but absolutely
I I think there's definitely some room
for me and one of those in one of those
versus yeah what kind of superhero would
you want to be outside of Spidey outside
of Spidey I want to be invincible I want
to be invincible very bad Seth I know
you're making the movie
I don't know if you saw the flaunt
article but I'm working on being
becoming a superhero so I love that and
we get that would be the role to play it
that'd be amazing that or you know my
Robin or Dick some some form of
Nightwing Dick Grayson Robin that would
be that would be a dream come true to
you those are the those those were the
my favorite superheroes and some people
might not know that you are a proud nerd
we were talking about comic-con
off-camera before we started so how much
fun is that for you huge fun I mean I
didn't have anything to do with this
comic-con this year but I went anyway I
dragged my friends down and we you know
I took them all over and got a bunch of
toys and comic books and stuff thing
well I gotta say judging by your
Instagram too you are clearly already in
shape for superhero the status I would
say he's got these flaunt pictures out
that are just oh my gosh tell me about
your fitness routine a little bit right
now how many hours a day are you in the
gym first of all and what what's your
diet like um my diet I eat a lot do you
have to yeah yeah yeah you definitely
have to eat a lot so it's it's kind it's
kind of not fair because people asked
what do you eat for breakfast I had a
stack of pancakes and waffles what did I
have for lunch guys
you eat egg whites you meat vegetables
only only raw eggs and no I honestly I
just it's it's I get up early in the
morning I go to the I workout I go to
the gym I don't I think I'd probably you
know I don't drink that's a lot of it
like setting out the booze really I mean
it slims it it's amazing but nothing
there's no crazy thing that I do that's
like some secret I it's just get up in
the morning go to the gym try and eat
right and just and what it is is just
keep doing it you know if you're gonna
go if you're gonna get up and you're
gonna go to the gym for three weeks and
think your body's gonna change it's just
not if you think that you know you're
gonna spend three months doing it your
body's gonna change it's just you got a
it's got to be your new it's just got to
be what you do this is just part of my
life this part of my day this is what I
do and
and you can maintain it but if you just
think that you're gonna go to your you
know trainer and say hey can you make me
look like this in a month right look at
you go
sorry many bounced right on your back
exactly linear but as long as you I
would just say consistency that's that's
really the main thing is just stay
consistent and then you're and then
you're good to go
sure wow that's inspiration I think for
all of us thank you for that you know it
wouldn't be a complete interview if I
didn't ask about Drake and Josh sure are
the ties officially cut between you two
no no no okay no look we're we I have
we've been together for 18 years Josh
and me me and Josh so and we've been so
close and it was it was just one of
those things that we were you know I've
been talking to him and he's been
telling you about the engagement and
then I saw on social media the wedding
and I I didn't hear about it so it's
just one of those things like didn't
even tell me and I had to find out on
social media and then you're like you
know what fine then I'm like wait that
was I probably shouldn't have done that
just brotherly but it's like sibling
rivalry for a minute but no I mean we've
gone through every UPS and up and down
that you can think of that to two guys
can go through me we've done our 18-hour
days on set and what are you doing
afterwards going to your house and
watching movies and playing video games
even though we've spent all day together
and then there's other times where I'm
only speaking dialogue to him you know
it's like no sorry I don't want to talk
but it's just what brothers go through
you know what best friends and it's the
yin and yang of brotherly love yeah were
you surprised that that got as much
media attention I was shocked I was
shocked I couldn't believe it I mean
what a slow news day I was like trump
can't you tweet something like just do
something to get the to get the
attention off of off of this yeah but
yeah I was I was really surprised and
and what I was more surprised that was
how the fans went after Josh I was that
bummed me out because I was you know I
was reading the comments and thinking
wait a minute you know I can say it but
you can't I was like get wanting to
defend Josh Oh easy guys easy this is
between us you know
well Twitter gets a little wider
they got well so I had to call them down
a little bit but but no I mean
everything is fine I mean we I mean you
guys have talked since yeah yeah yeah
totally
we it's I mean it is what it is dude I
love the kid III want to I would work
with them until I'm 80 years you know I
want to make grumpy old men with the guy
I want to make the odd couple when we're
old you know yeah and and so yes and no
hard feelings it's just that's when
you're when you've been so close to
somebody for so long I mean there's just
certain things that you know hey what
did you do come on man like yeah yeah
and Twitter is just such an instant that
that's that's the other thing and
everybody just jumped on it and I
couldn't believe the the press that it
gotten all this I'm like oh my god I had
no idea I just bummed out in the morning
yeah well I'm glad all is well on that
front the bromance lives on definitely
solid good to hear are there any real
talks about a reunion I know you've said
you'd be open to it if the story was
right is that something that that is
really in the works you know you got to
talk to peck gosh I would love to do it
I would love to I mean I I always say in
this situation I'm the John Lennon of
the Beatles I if there's time if it's in
our schedules yeah and it's right I
would I would jump in it in a second
because there's I've done multiple I've
done it like for example there's actors
that I've done TV shows with movies with
another TV show with a pilot with and
still don't have the the the connection
and and that I have a job you know the
chemistry it's just isn't there and to
what what John what I have with Josh is
so unattainable in this business to be
able to have somebody that I can look at
Josh we were just working last year on
grandfathers we hadn't worked together
for 10 years
and we would do a scene and then he'd be
like hey Drake and I look at him he
wouldn't even have to speak I was go I
know I got it don't worry I know exactly
I know you're gonna tell me dude I'll do
this I know I'll do the wheel we can
literally talk to each other like but no
no no okay I know I know and we already
know we're saying to each other and
people are watching us going what what's
going on and then all of a sudden they
say action and we're right in cue
and that's just I mean that's near
unattainable in this in this industry in
this business and it's like so to have
that is so special and I would I would I
would I would go back to it and in a
heartbeat yeah yeah is it crazy to you
too is it crazy to you though how
obsessed people still are with the show
like so passionate well as my mind I
have six year old I have six seven eight
year olds coming up to me you know oh my
gosh I'm like I can't believe you want
to live when we were on TV and that
you're watching the show and they love
it and it's really cool it's such a
rewarding feeling to be able to have you
know like I said a six year old a 16
year old a 26 year old a 46 year old and
then their grandparents all say we sat
around and watched you as a family and
it was one of the shows that we could
sit around and watch as a family and not
pull our eyes out or pull our hair out
going oh why are kids making us watch
this right we can't watch it it's too
too kidney you know it's too much for
the kids but that was really cool
it was really awesome to to have a show
that's so universal like that it doesn't
have a it's like full house is a great
isn't it is it is one like that you
doesn't matter what age you are it
doesn't matter what area you grew up in
it full house is on TV you're sitting
down and watching yeah and you're gonna
and you get that homey feeling of like
oh this is this is home you know and I
think that's what Drake and Josh does
for a lot of people and and with the
social media with the memes and the
quotes and all that I think there's been
like it helps the resurgent keep and
keep it alive right right but it's it's
it's just really cool to hear a family
go this was the one time we could sit
down as a family and our kids were
laughing we were laughing we were all
enjoying it together and then even when
the kids would get up and go to school
we we would still watch the show you
know so that was that it's really cool
are you still tight with other people
from the cast yeah I mean I I see
Jonathan all the time I actually been
working him out at the gym and Nancy who
played our mom on the show I just worked
with her we do this fun thing on YouTube
called where's Walter uh-huh
it's sort of taking a it's it's a play
on Drake and Josh sort of what would
have what happened why was it canceled
what you know we go to this whole metal
world that we've written and created and
so you should definitely check that out
if you're a fan of Drake and Josh but
but yes the Craig and Eric Alec Alec and
Scott who played who played Craig and
Eric they they came they came back and
worked on some stuff I I see Halliday
Yvette I'm calling about her name's
Yvette who played Helen on the show he's
on every TV show on TV right now just
yeah everybody I was just with Dan
Schneider who you know the creator of
the shows with him two weeks ago so that
is all still very much into that that's
that's why I find it so funny when you
know yeah I said because ties are code
whatever but that's like what I was I
should have just texted that to him you
know he's been cranky because we are a
family I mean we I talked to them all
the time I was with Dan for a week you
know just recently all of the cast and
the quarry even the crew members I mean
all that I was with I was with crew
members from Drake and Josh from 10
years ago that I just you know we're
like family we just hanging out and you
know just seeing how's the family kind
of thing you know exactly we really are
a real family so that's amazing I love
hearing that now I want to get back to
the music we have an exclusive
performance for you guys to watch I got
to see it earlier it's so good why don't
you tee it up for us
tell them what you're about to play and
what they need to know about the song
okay
this let's see what do you need to know
about this song it's awesome no this is
this is my single honest off of my new
EP honest and this is a stripped-down
acoustic version so it's a little bit
different than than the album and hope
you enjoy it
[Music]
spread like a wildfire what I preview
another weapon small you feel my lungs
and it gets me higher why do I have to
let you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now card in your undertow
[Music]
is it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
how awesome was that you guys thank you
so much for coming great so the honest
EP is out right now where can folks get
it I any where music sold it Spotify
iTunes all the all those ugly about
Amazon I don't know
wherever people buy music now it's
available everywhere so go check it out
go to borders or anything yeah yeah I
don't think that's happening okay so I
want to get to a few more fan questions
before you let you go before I let you
go Sarah wants to know where do you see
yourself in five years music television
both yeah both I mean entertainment I I
want to be in five years I hope I'm I'm
producing and writing and directing and
touring and everything all the bugs
Holly about question here from Sierra
what is your relationship status my
relationship status
I put me right on the spot ya know I
have a girlfriend for your ad and yeah
she inspire any music um yeah you know I
mean everyone in my life inspires my
music I don't think that you know
there's not one specific love song I've
written that I'd be like oh that was
about her you know and all kind of melts
yeah it's just yeah it's just you know
all everything kind of just is inspirati
but yeah you know it's it's good Sarah
wants to know is she in the industry
they want to know who she is
yeah she's in the industry she was
actually just on this cool little
snapchat show called the snaps for
BuzzFeed which was pretty funny yeah
cool yeah but yeah she's you know she's
in the industry she's rocking it trying
can you tell us who she is anything her
name's Janet geez go on go on the
Instagram or something sure you get
alright yeah yeah can it underscored
Vaughn or something how did you guys
meet just mutual friends I was I was a
friend of mine
his daughter was out visiting and then
she was friends and we were all just
hanging out and I was like hey you're
really cool that generally is a good
time yeah yeah all right thank you so
much for being here great to see you
thank you all so much for watching we
can continue the conversation on Twitter
and Instagram I am at sobytia' Lacey he
is at Drake Val thank you for watching
eg live don't forget to subscribe like
comment all that good stuff for more
from Entertainment Tonight we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]